- Are you afraid
to leave the house
because you don't wanna run into
your woman hating ex-boyfriend
who cheated on you
with your mother?
Me too.
This little exercise
I learned on Instagram
will really help you
conquer your fears.
Do one thing every
day that scares you.
Personally, spiders
scare the shit out of me.
Oh, and prostitution.
I'm gonna do that one.
(horn blast)
I'm fit and I'm fun, but
I've always been afraid
that no one would
wanna pay me for sex.
It's time to face
my insecurities
and really put myself out there.
I like your
freckles, by the way.
Where did you get them?
Well it is slow going right
now, but we're having fun, so.
(giggles)
Oh, hot meat alert!
Ah, wish me luck!
You boys lookin'
for a good time?
- No, no.
- OK, well have a good night!
You have to remember, everyone
you meet is fighting a battle
you know nothing about.
You can't take
things personally.
Hey, do you know if the
customers use Venmo?
Eesh, somebody's
fighting her own battle.
Oh, a Prius,
environmentally friendly
and hopefully horny.
- Uber?
- Hey there, Uber.
You lookin' for some action?
- No, I'm lookin' for Rebecca.
- I can be whoever
you want, baby.
- Where am I takin' ya?
- Oh, I guess we could
go back to my place.
My roommate's got
an improv show.
(sirens)
Oh, lights!
Awesome, another fear, jail.
(screams) Spider!